so the rock I want to make some garyvee
originals
you know these videos that we do ad hoc
not the askgaryvee shows not the
keynotes and today I want to make a
video about what just happened oh I love
you New York what just happened
here's what happened I'm on jury duties
my Duty's Duty my entire calendar is
cleared right they give us a very long
lunch what do I do
I don't sit and chill it out I don't sit
and say well I don't have anything
scheduled I email the team we bang out
episode 114 of the askgaryvee show I
email Matt my assistant he's hanging out
over there
it's kind of creepy looks looks super
suspicious
anyway anyway Matt's here so what we're
gonna go through a bunch of stuff that
we have to execute against I have to
pause right after I do this video Phil
Toronto from vayner/rse the fund is
coming and having a meeting that was
going to be at 11:30 p.m. tonight he's
coming to meet me at 1:00 basically what
I'm fascinated by is that people like to
say they hustle and I talk about working
the whole day and then I've talked to
you guys a lot about well it's not about
how much you sleep it's what you do
while you're awake and this is a perfect
example of something that I've watched a
lot of my contemporaries and a lot of
you the vaynernation right that say they
love to hustle when something happens a
meeting gets canceled right there's a
curveball it's a snow day right they
take that as vacation time instead of
adjusting to it see the truth of the
matter is being efficient executing
shooting for those big goals is
predicated on your actions do you take a
extra-long lunch from jury duty to say
you know what cool I'm going to chill
and watch youtube videos or do you
hustle your face off and try to cram as
much in you know I I'm excited that
that's my first thought now look I get
it I'm sitting on a high chair right now
and talking down to like you should do
this I'm really not I'm really not I'm
really not telling you what you should
do I'm really not trying to be a guru
I'm not really trying to be too cool and
say hahaha look at me not you I'm really
really really not really just making
these videos not for the people that you
find this condescending not for the few
people that find it motivational I'm
making this video for the people that
are foolish right the ones that tell me
to my face every day that yeah you know
and really want it
and don't recognize the actions that it
takes to get there so I'm making this
video for a very small percentage of you
to the left look no Gary thinks he's so
cool to the right
that's the best number complete
blindness no the middle the middle my
friends so many of you that actually
want this have the skills to do this
right and sometimes once in a while just
need to see a different version of it to
understand ah right
ah to me this is an AA video right did
you mail it in did you mail in that 15
minute 15 minute call got cancelled you
had a packed day 15 hour day they got
cancer what are you in that 15 minutes
and by the way sometimes those 15
minutes are absolutely worth calling
your mom
calling your daughter face on with your
kids but it's just making every minute
count
every minute has to count every minute
has to count if you want so much because
you just don't have as many of them as
you think you just don't